and Coco stream Coco from Team Coco
that's us my name's Erin this is Beth
murasky she's in the chat Jason O'Malley
creeper in the corner hey now while
we're doing a little fun thing today
happy Monday it's and we're doing
another 360 stream if you want to see us
in 360 here we are it's this camera
right here and if you can see it I'm
gonna make it just come over a little
bit there's 360 cam right there pretty
great Beth it has the link in the chat
for you YouTube folks if you want to
check out the 360 stream to see it in
360 you're going to see that's right
part of it is you're gonna see a mic
stand right really close to the thing
yeah should I move it closer to us
actually moving close to us how's it
going everybody stomp Brad
good to see you go go Mason water boy
I'm already boring TSA's water boy well
thanks don't watch us have fun not
watching us today we're gonna play a
little game and look really cool called
the Magic Circle and this was described
as a game within a game yeah so
basically you are in an unfinished video
game and the developers you're fighting
against the developers I think they are
like they like come in and like they're
like the gods of Olympus kind of and
they mess with you which couldn't be a
more passive aggressive game and I Spit
on the 360 cam so you're welcome 360
folks and because III is going on yeah
so we thought it'd be fun to play a game
that kind of is about making video games
also tonight on YouTube around 7:30
Conan and I will be appearing live on
the YouTube stream III coverage so look
for that I will not be wearing a shirt
that says sleazy no I'll probably be
wearing a nice cable knit sweater or a
blue shirt my mom picked out for me so
their team cocoa will probably tweet
something about it where it happens
that's right with a link exactly some
brands know we are not in George
Lansky's office oh I remember being
scared
hey left raspiness good to see you Aaron
you need some tattoos you thought about
tattoos I'm a wimp I don't want to get
tattoos I'll draw I will draw on my body
every day of a giant Punisher skull but
I with marker but I won't this is cool
it's so relatable white boys who a
Francaise can we try to beat the game
within the game within the stream time
yes
challenge accepted no how long would the
game do you think nope Isaiah this is
Isaiah productions this is the Magic
Circle Chris says they're at school sky
Patrol says they like bananas thank you
I like the girls voice I am Joey cannoli
there you go thank you for subscribing
to us brother Todd good to see you
oh here we are
all right so let's see here are three
zoom hey Jen ours got jumps this is cool
it's like all weird cell shading and
drawing like oh this is cool oh that's
in love I love video games now hey now
whoa this is awesome very weird
first of all let's do our favorite thing
which is putting on subtitles subtitles
how do I do this creature pop-up text
yes please oh yes I guess this is all on
help oh yeah there it is I like how you
pointed like to the giant TV you're just
like there it is I thought on the TV I
turn this down is this too loud creeper
alright here we go
yeah Hannah says you should always love
video games oh the 360 view is kind of
dumb sorry David Schmidt you're not
doing it right did you look around did
you see what are we having here that's
cool look at you can look you know let's
see the other side of the studio oh you
can see you know you can see these cool
photos you can see a cool photo of who
is that Jeff Goldblum with Kesha
over there you go alright everyone
always makes one of the holes in our
ceiling that's true that's true we still
have holes which we thought would be
patched up this is cool by the way is
that a good dude no mocap suit finally
oh so this game is submit the idea of
Magic Circle is this is a game that's
only half-finished and we're a character
in the half-finished game kind of like
what's that Will Farrell movie
it's change of the fiction yet oh take
Stuart oh look at this
[Music]
someone said I see Aaron's big face
because what they're looking at - listen
whoa the is great sometime
Vladimir's watching this well his
brother Stewart's loudly here's the
thing I think that now if you saw this
in real life - giant eyes floating
around this would be horrified I'd be
glad that like our over alien or the
thing is like I think video games are
going to help us when aliens invade guys
I know internet doesn't like to talk
about aliens but here's the thing if
aliens were to ever show up on earth I
think we would be fine with it just
because video games have taught us not
to fear aliens you know the Covenant
actually shows up guys back me up on
this do you guys first of all believe in
aliens I know you do don't even turn i
[Music]
sat and looked at blaze crotch Jesus not
angry zebra I gotta cover up note to
self don't yeah don't show crotch - 360
cam 360 is very cool
Thank You mock thank you it is oh wait
let's go over here oh my god
this is so cool I'm feel like this is
just a way this is just like to just
about video games like relatable
for ya
well people hashtag relatable I missed
Erin's crotch guys stop licking my
crotch to the 360 camp
don't make me now I have to sit this way
bunch of perverts on the stream just
imagine you can get married to an alien
it would be so cool it would only be
cool I think if your physiological stuff
match do you know what I'm saying oh
gosh no I'm talking about guys yep
people never think about that but like
how did Superman have sex he didn't you
know he couldn't he was he was
Kryptonian escaped I don't know which
one your artist did it but putting the
elementary lock way way above the door
means that a hundred ten percent tears
just spin in touch from certain place
alright now this is getting annoying
the player never ever looks up fix it
nobody looks up ooh wait where should we
go now you're playing with portals guys
mysterious let's go in here use cloud
realm quest great objects can be thrown
hold r1 to Inger throw release to throw
oh I see we got to throw it up there
right oh yeah we're not gonna we're
actually going to night tonight Conan
and I will be on a YouTube livestream
honey about e3 will be at e3 7:30
although we're not gonna be at I don't
know where we're I gonna be yeah I think
I don't know which place we're gonna be
at but yes we're very excited you guys
have have you been
have you been pay attention III coverage
what do you like so far that you've seen
get up boom perfect now you're playing
with portals same deal spawn the life
key alright alright got the lozenge in
there where's Jordan slansky oh boy
oh no Dishonored 2 whoo I'm in a porno
what are you talking about
I think you mean guy if you're confusing
a guy fieri
Aaron do you remember me sister um I
know a lot of Tories believe it or not
so if you're one of the Tories I
remember then yes can I run I gotta say
I love the cell shading in games it's
awesome quake origins ooh
Skyrim remastered Dishonored 2 quick
origins would be dope see if thieves who
I like it oh my god good lord guys stop
arguing oh my god it's like hanging out
my parents this game is weird Vladimir I
agree that's a giant hand there's
another hand oh no is just that hand is
that kind of it oh ok
I'll stay
maybe I just do I just lip-sync this
it's like lip-sync battle but video game
video game alright here we go
hero you are trapped my minions will
destroy you wait how do I fight bro bro
how do I fight bro hey bro
ah ah how do I fight
well I'm in ghosted oh cool
this game is super weird but I'm into it
we're playing the Magic Circle everybody
it's a game about a game wait so
sometimes you have to die maybe to then
deal with ghosts objects because I
couldn't come across this look at what's
happening over here yeah like how are
you dude how much how much drugs did
somebody take do I just jump do I just
jump off this name get in there she says
alright alright
oh look at this dirty platform yeah this
these are random things of light seemed
definitely like I should be walking on
them we need to go deeper sis spring
fart yes spring fart we shall go deeper
that's gonna be on my tombstone so weird
Trent Phillips yeah I agree this is
super weird
go we're going aging I am looking up
your beard look at my beard iron you can
see O'Malley working on the oh yeah
that's true you see a mouse right here I
rethink the audio yes this hombres has
yeah you can see what's going on down
here yeah there's the 360 what's
happening here oh and the person said
they're watching on a Samsung tablet is
having trouble I've seen all this game
it's pretty dope oh and ER Spangler
Andrew Spangler do you think we can
complete it in 90 minutes yeah we don't
know where's the walking carrot look
tonight hope LaRosa
tonight wait we just beat the game
you think I sound jelly but purpose
Trump's experience and you know oh boy
it's gonna be like a cult situation to
just skip this you can skip it there's
the thing of what up to thank you might
a deaf but timed and deaf
both of my favorite games and while I
say de Pepe sure my favorite game I've
said this before but I really like breed
wait what's happening well you're seeing
this right I'm not the only first to
seen the Magic Circle Start screen
talking to me yeah that's cool okay Pro
Mode doing it let's get into pro mode
how long will the live stream be
jungle-gym mania I don't know we'll see
not that not super I mean it's ongoing I
mean 15 20 30 minutes and I like that
hey you finished it Tori have we met
before
if we have then I remember you trippy
eyes alive productions sir Hubner no one
knows what's happening oh whoa look at
this bet
oh whoa this is dope oh wait whoa I can
look around whoa holy crap this is
awesome oh we could go into oh my god we
could go into the Start screen this is
insane what's back there
dude this is madness okay that's awesome
this is totally awesome Adrian says my
junk is dope All Right game on here we
go
Oh even spring fart says whoa
but they're scared yeah
hashtag sleaze power say I got sleeping
up our sleeves power yeah so is this
like Tron yeah it's gonna happen in the
game three 360 cam is literally just the
O'Malley camp yeah if you just watch a
Mele Chico thing
whoa dude what's going on to the bottom
there time is passing this is creepy hat
huh dude what's going on this game is
insane
whoa what we have a hand whoa weird well
we're out of math class oh so like they
thankfully developers they're like the
gods or whatever like the guys whoa
that's crazy
yes start by breaking me okay
this is crazy
am I going
[Music]
this game is crazy by the way my
nerdiness is being recognized as a rare
not always I think I think some
programmers like oh cool stick my hand
in the crack yes please oh do it what
could possibly happen oh this is dope
whoa whoa whoa nice this is awesome
wait take life whose life okay to place
a circle trap in the ground are two okay
whoa this is like a trippy portal I
always stick the hand in the cracks this
qex como yep
is the Sturridge
oh my God look at this I hope that this
is actually like real coding stuff we
should get Daniken here I'd be like it
tell us what's happening yes
live at it crack is wack yo you're right
I lost 100 pounds it looks like you
found them I don't know what that means
but thank you well showed easily deleted
content yes please I'll team up for
overwatch whoa look at this oh I see
this is what they were planning on
putting in the world but they didn't
so I can remake things that they've
unmade see that's cool oh here comes the
intern this is horrifying oh man alright
Danielle I'll tell Conan you want him
but someone said there's a vr version of
super hot coming out oh my god you got
to play that doesn't like the flailing
dude yeah don't have with the live
playtesters yo why you played this game
man because this game looks cool man
ou can touch my toilet water is blue and
that's more interesting this will have
fun flushing your toilet and staring at
it I will say it is kind of cool to see
a toilet flush I mean it's pretty you
open the back thing and although oh yeah
actually so toilets are pretty just like
a good place to store money great place
to store money that's true yeah or like
what else can you start back there like
books ha peanuts peanuts all I wouldn't
take food into the bathroom
do you take food in the bathroom only
like maybe ever having a bath oh no you
don't eat in the back the Reese's Pieces
in a bath oh you know whatever guy
bastards then you got to know how to fix
the clothes the cracks Oh God I've been
ghosted tap l22 reclaim your life oh I
see alright I wish I could run in this
game
oh wow this is the most passive
aggressive game I've ever played change
lock knock it down
Kevin gee while we're playing the Magic
Circle today III is going on in this
game is about this game is about making
games so that would be a proposed I put
up poll on the day of ye uh Oh what do i
do what do I do I like though I think
he's nice
creature trapped who let's edit him oh
cool ah this is insane this game is
insane dude let's see edit field
oh I see oh I see we can rewrite things
Oh ima oh man ooh
I am a best Oh No yeah I am a monster
I'm the bet yeah yeah I have a bet I bet
I moved by this is awesome
by the way people who made the magic
circle this is awesome basic ground
movement whoa what can I do here oh my
god this is crazy
I know I can't move I attack with melee
Jesus this is horrifying
oh I see oh we can give my enemies are
oh nothing
Beth enemy other hollers Jesus all right
my allies are here oh oh wait a second
we can make you my oh you wanna be my
Ally oh yeah we give you pals I can be
picked up false I'm gonna give you back
your legs then please and I'll give you
back your tea - but cuz we're allies
yeah I need to alright it's great exit
now how do I let you go how do I let you
go oh yeah look we're pals
a lot like I bet I think a color in the
hair maybe yeah
although yeah you have a pretty serious
underbite in this game yeah let's go oh
look and look when I walk is color this
is so cool man I got a cool Ally this is
great
you and me Beth is how it is this is
everyday this is everyday walking to get
some salad yeah this is busy us going to
Starbucks pretty great hyper virus are
playing the game this game called the
Magic Circle it's really cool alright
god this guide loves to talk damn son
there you are
oh yeah you have the same eyes yeah
beautiful greens it's too can I take
this life back beauty can I take this
live back from you pal are you at yeah
are you going here where do we go this
way
did you come out this way
I see we can take we can give like magic
and take magic weird bug underbite uh
where do we go here oh wait I think we
want to go over is that where we came
from we came from down there mmm the
curse of every game where to go well
this looks like something over here oh I
have James Urbaniak by the way as the
voice loved James Urbaniak if you like
the Venture Brothers you've heard James
Urbaniak voice before I met James
Urbaniak could talk to for a long time
at who at can I stick my hand in there I
met him I did this Twitter benefit for
Haiti with like Ashton Kutcher and a
bunch of people and he was there him and
I talked for a long time and Charlie day
is a huge fan of James Urbaniak and came
over and talked to us for a long time
and it was really great it was a very
fun night oh look at all this oh there's
another howler down there zapped him
let's edit the howler I'm gonna make
dude my enemies are nothing No
now he knows that hunting you is a
sucker's game my alum ease up allies are
at here oh this is great you can just
turn all the wait the colors aren't
gonna attack each other right in years I
think I do
I think the back one does another how
are you let's see that guy lon
well let's go look at this mushroom yeah
dancing it's going on this mushroom
situation at this mushroom
whoa-ah at the field insane
because it's risky to speak freely
yeah you learn to unseeing it's pretty
great
see you Maddie a star thank you for
joining us have you had fun don't take
mushrooms kids this idiot okay I'm
Monica I don't care about that taking
this back
Wow I'm full of life you know let's fill
it up
why would I want to fill an enemy no
thanks
I know I'm learning about the thingy I
like how you could take stuff back which
is good oh it's this fill a lie ooh
all right let's keep going let's just
going on in here I think I have a couple
hollers with me I got to do I got a
couple hollers rocking it out
you got your crew that's my crew all
right go now that's my question
Taylor Swift has her girl gang you have
your howler yeah I got my best gang
digne best their gang your best
it's the best surround yeah no and it's
the best one man all the way Brandon be
a philia bro
it's like the colors in this game what's
like the colors in this game all right
that looks like something down there I
like sticking my hands and crack whoo no
I'm never on thank you for that holla
are we doing here is this the right way
no one knows Coco for mushrooms too said
toot if you took mushrooms while playing
this game oh I already would this way
son of them that's get out of my way
bets
yeah friend find a life 2016 Beth loves
Taylor Swift don't you boo
hey she's fine I like her music what
Tube account thank you orcas Torian Beth
sweet honey respond that's creepy that's
sweet honey oh this makes me hungry
that's what Jill
nothing here's what's in here by the way
good god this place yeah I am wondering
that actually ha what is what are we
betting on that this guy's actually
right he's definitely aren't any right
eventually am I supposed to be doing
this cuz this looks like I could die
very easily here guys this story way to
go anyone have any idea we're going back
to the forest of here I feel we gotta
get up there to that dude right this
seems like a really bad idea actually
let's not go this way new plant we're
not going this way uh-oh uh-oh uh-oh
let's go let's go let's go back into the
weird forest you will die thank you dr.
Nick up up I hear something weird
I guess you were supposed to live out a
fairy tale born to end some war when
your sword got big enough ah sexy the
gods would have had to agree on all your
powers so you get none getting creature
here was abandoned by the gods that
seems very sad be pissed
alright okay is there something yet
happy feed I wish I had the force is
there something that's going to help us
with this I already went through there
where do I go
I hate RIS Smith I'm paying attention to
the chat what are you talking about what
you talk about risks we love you all
love you all I just don't know where to
go au revoir this is an amazing game
yeah we're playing the Magic Circle
today it's super fun it's a game about
games how meta oh here we go wait a
second oh here we go here we go here we
go think we're gonna meet like an int
maybe it's just basically just this dude
talking god you're so angry at the gods
dude chill out and listen and complete
rockin yeah I agree let's start saying
more
your mom loops oh snap
here's a mushroom can I do say with it
ooh my allies are wizards there's a
wizards oh my god we haven't met a
wizard yet
ooh I move wait let's have a move we
can't move anything oh I see we can give
wait a second check this out know what
we have yeah that's my allies are also
mate Pokemon yeah I want to also be an
ally to this wait we can okay I can be
picked up let's pick him up oh yes all
right you know what I bet if I took the
howlers legs away I could probably make
this thing walk but I don't want to take
that one's legs away it seems mean yeah
I think it's like now little guy now
that you have a stake in the in the
little monster you don't want to do
anything bad to them you know all right
interesting uh was I supposed to do
something to that I have no idea
it feels like I'm supposed to do
something to it right wait and it holler
no I could give this thing legs should I
take I'm gonna take the legs off sorry
Beth can I take your legs real quick um
you can borrow them all right I'm just
gonna borrow your legs real quick
I move by nothing sorry sorry
oh man that's so sad oh no this is very
sad
I moved by ground okay move oh look hey
look at this
wait it's a Maya ally or not oh he's got
weird eye all right I can't I can't
we're trying to beat this game in 90
minutes it's not gonna happen
sorry mushroom B didn't have leg all
right I can't I can't you've got eyes
[Music]
so sad I should just be able to give
everything legs all right here we go all
right let's go we're exploring we know
we're supposed to go here anyone know
borrow my legs whoa pass through the
dark forest to reach the fort okay
whoa dude look at this I love this this
is the menu this is awesome this is
crazy this game's gonna be fun in VR I
bet ah all right find the mushroom so
where are you going your kids pass
through the forest to reach the fort is
that the that's that is the fort we went
over there we saw this guy man I hate it
when games don't tell you where to go
just be clear about it man don't be coy
somebody go I'm happy to just go
wherever you want me to do you think we
jump back down there what do you think
we do we've activated this dude we've
activated all the dudes really yeah a
good donor can we go this way oh we're
gonna die that's death can't go that way
[Music]
give the mushroom thanks no thanks
follow the rainbow follow the rainbow
where's the rainbow taste the rainbow
does anyone have skittles hungry got
your two best pals I know I got Beth in
a holler or two Beth's get double the
best double the fun
while we're going in circles okay well
oh what's that something up there
nobody knows all right here we are in
here we've done this we saw we took our
extra life oh all right let's do it
ah Jesus
oh wow they killed the crap out of him
yeah those dopes good job I love to kill
good job you like eating your own kind
B&B Bethan bleh B&B - bleh sitting in a
tree we're actually not sitting in a
tree we are in a bunch of trees oh here
we go all right we're back all right we
finally made it to the dark forest nope
not true because that's the way we went
into the dark forest I don't get where
I'm supposed to go here somebody help me
yeah we want to go up there man we want
to go to the big hand hand sir way
through this dumb forest am I missing
something the answer is yes
okay let's try it again we're gonna go
this way we're gonna take a left the
road less traveled they say and that's
made all the difference you know what's
funny is I recently read a whole review
of that poem by Robert Frost oh yeah
and Oh found a wheel ooh activate heavy
doors boss
and it's actually one people think guys
quick quick poetry chat on the on stream
Coco I'll put a link to as we can all
read it together it's actually the road
less traveled now here we go it's
actually different thing the guy is
convincing himself it's that he made the
right choice it's not that he actually
took the road less traveled by yeah it's
more depressing than that it's like a
little like louis c.k bits when he's
like i'm doing this bit because it's
like behind the guy in the airplane
stuff or whatever this is just like two
people bitching at each other like i
spent my life in my life getting
different jobs yeah yeah wits go work at
Target don't tell me - alright I know
you guys hate each other I'm not gonna
be your pawn but I will take some
mushrooms don't want to edit this
mushroom I guess Oh what is that too far
should I take this mushroom or leave it
wait my hollers at oh no my hollers are
here dope what's this weird thing
from the subtext alright so the fort in
the fonts the hero is banished do you
decide the chowder hey some of them are
nice anyway no not Greece Oh see look
you're an intelligent race yeah for
generations mother all right Christina
you got a shout out there you go it's
splatted what's with the shrooms
yessiree guy I love shrimps actually
would I try shrooms it's scary but you
know I don't like you know trophic
things not psychotropic I would do
Flintstones vitamins because they're
good for you yeah they're delicious
what's your favorite Flintstone I hated
them I had to take the chalky ones when
I was little Oh see I like the chalky
ones I used to have that weird and then
like my mom found a bunch of moldy ones
oh they get moldy that's awful yeah I
think I put an orange oh here we go
man guys somebody peed all over the
walls come on up time time yep yep yep
get it guys refusing oh man there's pee
all over the floor Oh guys it writes
itself huh something I'll edit it allies
but holding oh oh okay great and call my
guys to me I feel like something is
gonna happen in here
it's like bad
oh hey look at this I made a little
spaceship
oh hey weird hey wait now we're in space
1 but the worth great this is awesome
all right now we're its now we're like
dude this is awesome
whoa this is doe this scheme is insane I
love this game this is a fun game magic
circle folks well done the menacing
music and I love - it's like the
graphics are so crap in the world oh wow
this is awesome this is so dope
do you say holodeck handle looks like
Wolfenstein in space do you that
elevator door they won't open for just
you I can help you track it down maybe
find being hyper nedick's this is so
awesome
look at this dude
am I gonna get hurt if I walk on
oh look at that guy now your eyes match
the goo on the floor oh look at this guy
corpse discovered oh whoa cool oh man
ooh there was an episode of the x-files
where Mulder was trapped in a game with
the gunman whoa awesome it was great it
was very 1999 I don't want to make good
x-files rounds my ally I'll make him my
ally just because I feel like everybody
should be my Ally you know I'd be picked
up true let's take this corpse
I moved by nothing
let's go corpse maybe we have to use you
know use them for like a handprint or
something you know hibernate X is down
there what's this I'm being scanned I'm
gonna put them in here that's I'm sure
that's gonna do something right take
some life this is great this game is
dope I still think that this dude is
gonna be uh-oh
I still think this dude is gonna be our
enemy eventually like that's the way
things work cats we need corpses it's a
floating ship of death all right
Hey look I'm dance Oh
that's how I dance Mambo number 5 a
little bit of Monica in my life a little
bit of reader all I need a little bit
something and a little bit of you makes
me your man hey nothing Mambo number
feels great doesn't great some Mambo
number 5 I feel like I'm gonna throw
this dude into the electrical field
right cyber rat huh let's trap the cyber
rat and its cyber right yes please you
don't do anything I move background
I'm cyber out of taking your legs sorry
cyber right
let's just leave the cyber right there
for now sorry cyber right can I give
this corpse legs and it'll follow me do
you think do you think if I give him it
see a lot as a court cut a corpse walk
around guys we're getting into some very
existential questions here
[Music]
oh I just created a zombie you know what
in that case definitely my allies army
all right follow me pal oh look at this
ah this is great oh man I got this deal
with me god oh my god enough with the
god situation up here oh brother
see this guy's gonna be a bad guy I'm
telling you man he's gonna be a bad guy
look can I help ya DS guy you know what
this is like the Doctor Who
the Pandorica yeah it's a trap sorry it
was two years ago this guy is definitely
a bad guy all right I don't quite get
what I'm supposed to do here let's let's
go female though yeah oh oh I see it's
just a whole thing about how get girls
and games well I got dope arms whoa
allies will attack any house with
creatures they find any circular areas
surrounding her weight points position
your a point for aeons okay oh great
you con that scanner at the elevator it
wants a second hero but my guess is
anyone will do this dude is such a bad
guy he's turning us in dude him alright
let's go well I already got my boy the
corpse with me I'll take this dude -
lets go
I got a zombie look at my crew I'm going
deep dude let's hit the club look at
this let's hit the club you know time to
get the club with my crew what's going
on over here so I throw something over
here
[Music]
that's a waypoint wait how do I get the
Waypoint back don't go in there
let's go this way
yeah we got to go into this elevator oh
you know what
Oh see I have to get two corpses and put
them in each one of the thing there
slurp some more life hold on I gotta go
grab this guy out of the thing I pick
him up thank you oh he's all burnt up or
something my ghosts in them or something
mister attack this game we're playing is
called Magic Circle and it's really fun
isn't you it's fairly new came out July
2015 like a year ago open I know why oh
you know what this is how you do it
wait wait how do I pick this guy alright
it's not here I guess I got to put the
Waypoint
in there I bet right somebody go over
there hey get in there go over there's a
waypoint how do I do that again
I knew it they were too lazy to make
that scanner look for something specific
how do I get my peeps back guys come
back here's your right-hand man's squad
squad for everyone in formation yeah
now what let's go let's go up Gingras
what's up J says I feel like Jordan
should have a minesweeper stream I
wonder Jordan B he's got an analytic
mind he'd be pretty good a minesweeper I
feel like yeah ah dude look at this
dude's face you are really into breaking
games man you need to you can get hobby
cyber right get it boys get him
oh don't why are you just staying in the
elevator how do I undo there we go
uh-oh it looks like a thing out doorbot
ooh
[Music]
oops
who likes that at the doorbot ooh
lightning rod I've definitely taken a
lightning rod from this dude I move
background let's take I don't care about
robots so we'll take his legs attack
with nothing let's I'm gonna give you
some lightning activities
check out you're gonna get some cool
special lightning abilities yeah what do
you think about that this is so dope I
don't think I can go in there it oh dude
perfect you open the door for me thanks
dude
yeah you're pretty handy a howler to
have around yep
the developers were definitely on
shrooms this game is awesome though I
gotta say I like any games I've said
this before any games where yeah we were
never in space at all yeah it was
Radovan bish is 125 a.m. there thank you
for watching by the way guys if you're
wondering what this is we are also
streaming in 360 for you all Beth will
hit you with a link in the chat where
you can go to a special YouTube 360
stream and it's like you're sitting
right here with us
yeah only without this my stench but
we're working on a youtube stench stream
yeah so you can also smell
smell-o-vision that's more like 6 or 7
new dental plan for you what 3d is the
z-axis for T is time 5d is emotions you
know like if we do something a 5d you'll
feel what we feel
60 so 60 is the smell and 70 goes back
to two yards 78 to do like the same
thing they've read a wrinkle in time
exactly it is my domain says or
historian destroy the moaning flying I
Oh spoon a kiss
I wish there is a nickel if I had a
nickel for every time someone said that
I'd have 35 cents cuz that's how many
times people have said that to me
scaped remain Eric last and thus March
for the blah okay fine love the game
design love the idea of this game
bickering is a little much but otherwise
we're liking it yeah I'm annoying great
guy now and Rouge does that mean I'm
annoying the gray guy in the game or am
i annoying as a great guy all the Grays
probably guys whoa that's dude scary oh
hey like a spacestation let's fill it up
what do we got here oh that seemed like
a bad idea
can't edit that's uh what is this
what's a jug at dillio I like them
I'm just everyone is gonna be you know
tumse house yeah there's nothing I
attack with nothing all right let's
bring him along right hey pal oh look at
this guy
ah you know I'm gonna admit let's name
which we named the jug adílio how about
I want to name the jug dillio after
we're gonna name it a jungle Malley Jack
O'Malley boom guys you gotta live you
know you gotta have fun you gotta have
fun it's a video game you know what are
we doing
O'Malley it's got your tongue motions
O'Malley does that a lot with this time
oh this is creepy
God how this go down look I I'm learning
from people watching a 360
actually cam that I'm a disgusting human
oh wow well you guys killed that really
quick good job who edit hyper though
locked by groupthink Oh once it's dead I
can't do stuff to it they're like the
creeper move out of the corner he just
has a different corner yeah he's got it
yeah you'd be over here but now it's
raided corners hey I discovered a rock
use the map to summon anything you've
edited even if it's dead everybody a
rock can I go through this Oh nope nope
dead I'm dead I'm dead
okay well just learned that was a bad
idea
what was that though yeah whoa now
there's like weird stuff happening lava
how do i oh I'm ghosted ooh look at this
since I'm ghosted I could pick up this
and put it here
you know like walk across you know
put one right there perfect so able to
get on that thing put another one over
here
[Music]
probably jump from there to there right
all right pretty great actually when I
do this this game is cool man I gotta
say oops and we can like walk and lava I
guess I don't know if I could pick this
thing up though I can't cuz I've been
ghosted I get more like that doesn't
work we're gonna go back into space in a
second how do I get over what can I take
life away from this thing No
all right it's a puzzle guy it's it's a
putt it's a platformer puzzle hey dark
Calla what's up thank you for joining us
here we go all right now I'm back here
becomes the problem I guess I can fill
these right
I'm so gonna die here fill that one dead
and I'm dead
ah that's cool I can't touch these
things I've kind of screwed myself
because here dammit how do I do that I
think I could take this life again right
okay now we're back now can i edit this
rock can i edit that rock over there is
my question how do i do far in a trap
well that didn't work
see I should have just jumped in a lava
and killed myself but wait a second can
I just pick up this rock
got all yours god I thought here we go
here we go oh that's way too far away
huh
and did it feel it's okay sorry guys I
think you're a little screwed just stay
there
get some life how do I get you guys over
here are you gonna die what you can't
abandon your friends I do but there's no
way to get you across
oh man look at my pals over there this
is how you treat us after all we've
wonder if I can I bring this might kill
you guys by the way are you ready there
they go they're dead I killed all of you
sorry now I've known I had someone I've
known isn't that life no wait a second
whoops I guess I gotta animate this guy
damn it but I don't think I have I can't
give you I can't I can't give him legs
Oh No I'm all alone now in this game
this sucks
yeah I'll make new friends as Rob I
spoke like a mercenary you'll make new
friends
thank you should've known you got this
back yeah so what do you actually want
maybe still someone's account and edit
the world like we do be my guest just do
it to that three-phased intern Koda
oh my personal brand what's so bickering
is that what it's like to make video
games be this big about the interns yeah
she's volunteering your time
whoa look at that tomorrow never was
I'll take that teleport acquired
can we picked up to where we taking this
teleport Thanks
[Music]
um should I just jump into the teleport
thing what do you think there's some
weird like
[Music]
what's going on here how'd it get over
there that's my question
[Music]
can I use this oh here we go here we go
whoa what the oh my god I don't care
what's supposed to happen
we still need to meet on what to do with
the tractor bye
I can schedule it super happy to keep
advising you know I got you tractor buzz
around here you know what I bet if I'm
dead you can't get me what do you think
about that Trek turbot that's right
suck it tractor BOTS suck it oh so
ghosted I gotta get down there how do I
do that I guess I had to do the life
thing the way to do it would be to get
somebody else if I had any friends which
I don't know you killed me and your
other sorry by accident but it was kind
of funny oh wait
telepods let's take the telepods first
of all it's sick the life I take this
telepods with me
but take this teleporting ability cute
and then yes I can be picked up we're
gonna pick you up I'm gonna throw this
at the at the teleport bot right here we
go I'm something to focus on yep yep yep
yep nope nope son of a against you
now why cuz I killed you why didn't you
kill me I don't like it when people
throw me into lava like not into Oh get
over yourself
get over here it's over how is this
gonna work I can't really Jim can I do
it how do i when the tractor bot has me
what do i what should I do
guys what should I do dishonorable death
by tractor bot what are the strange
strategies spewed a kiss I think
O'Malley is big help okay now what do i
do what do i do what do I do
I'm almost dead I'm almost dead oh I was
inside for a second dammit this is a
puzzler all right let's see maybe I can
go get this oh it's not working it keeps
it slowly like okay maybe I can I I can
edit to just pad right I can be picked
up can I pick it up though I just feel
like today here we go
oh wait a second maybe I can teleport
inside the thing that's not going work I
don't think anyone has played this game
in the stream no one is like she was
vice either yeah no is it like helpful
tips you know I'm gonna do I'm gonna
here's what I'm gonna do
I'm gonna get get over here drop that
there come back give it life right then
whip it at the tractor bomb oh man I
hope you guys are watching the 360 sure
with that that was hilarious look it
does just like slowly tilt it every
freak out did everybody freak out no
that's awesome nature allottee fail
that's real life that's how you know
it's real I watch this move
what if I throw this is the tractor bye
oh it only does that sucks
ah there it worked go go go go go yeah
maybe
alright tractor bot what now what now I
say tractor bot yeah own I got it my
enemies are no these are not everything
my enemies are the here no my enemies
are not to here my army of nothing my
allies yeah are here also I'm taking
this tractor beam
so now you're nothing
you move by nothing you are also I'm
renaming you because you killed me so
many times and I'm sorry I know I'm not
supposed to be petty but I'm renaming
you a joke yep
you're a joke thank you alright now did
you destroy my thing or what oh no I
ghosted it but I can get it back
Oh God let's dream broken Oh Valley
furnace I got a weird message on my
thing I gotta I think it's fine it I got
a message on this it was like your
streamers stops 3 meters nope but it
looks better now Wi-Fi signal what am I
supposed to go here nothing it's fine
back go back go back
well now are we wait is this the right
place
hey I want to go over there is where I
want to go
[Music]
at the Sun I don't know what it is
exactly
wait that sucks
great give me the clip in the washing
out don't think the clips a great call
for this house I don't think O'Malley
well seconds you're about to get an
eyeful ha ha do you have tape friends
it's bad idea all right
we beat the tractor thing let's go back
no way we're beating this game by the 15
minutes I'll just keep my hand we're
just like a piece of well you'll need a
tape to wrap around this thing or
something there any man like that would
just go around here yeah who will a chat
I can't see what it says but Aaron
should play with PewDiePie
we played me I did play a PewDiePie and
clueless gamer which is super fun I need
to take this somewhere else or that I
want to get over there is where I want
to get you know what I'm saying how do
we get
oh wait oh yeah now I can get over there
there we go let's go
zapper ooh the high-level fix here
I love it tape your life shrieking from
battle last release today it'll be
stealthy look at huh
Oh shady fridges at France awesome have
some delicious cheese and what a seven
friends yeah you you would have fun
using I told you this odo it was a nice
are truly Wow
oh my god this is getting like
depressing
yes years whoa oh god this is day like
sound horribly depressing the stage you
have to make yourself believe it long
ago the system generate unique offspring
from fire baby even says you could have
taken your friends with beam the beam
there's a lot of animosity
I can't do anything brother shouldn't
let this guy die
oh he's gonna our way is here that's
gonna kill me leave him there no yes
that saying this aloud how can the demo
be about anything else
the crowd has to see a charm for me 12
get up here first future as I get what
was I said at the end of the original
text adventure
all right I got you back oh boy a lot of
hybrids over here oh that's a lot of
high verse oh my god
I need more howlers
some for Boston isn't chat hi Boston hi
Boston this is some dead but time I
project this way I can get the holler
back
[Music]
it's going here
I like how you can hear the guy I hear
the guy talking about what is going on
not enough light for a trap anymore life
oh this is creepy I don't have any life
man hi ever Queen alien language whoa
God beast law and life man wow this
isn't good I ever Queenie Oh God
flamer I'll see what I need to do is Oh
God Oh No
Oh God go holler I'll holler is dead
hollers dead gotta run high verse are
after me
high vers are after me this isn't good
this isn't good
what is that that's the queen I think
I'm queen
anymore life anymore life I need more
life
I need more life oh god it's getting
intense man oh god I'm dead so dead
Oh risk our back here Jesus where do I
go now I remember where I'm supposed to
Kelly oh that's right in here
right nope
over this way were you guys ever sure
overwatch yeah well we'll stream over
watch me we'll play next week yeah yeah
well play with some folks we got some
having fun celebs coming by and yeah
we'll play overwatch next week that
sounds yeah
[Music]
I've got some menacing to have to do
this whole thing over I can't no here we
go
I can fly over here this life going I'll
go down you want to go down you nope
whoa I fell out of the thing
wait was that a real glitter of faked
glitch in this game that's crazy
how could you can't tell the difference
weird there we go
real glitch or fake glitch here we go
this guy ten years we've all aged 10
years yeah yeah yeah that's fine we're
down to minor fixes so it's project
director the most valuable thing I can
do now is your clue you guessed it
creator commentary should we go oh my
god please no
should we go fight the Huayra Queen or
go up on that mountain over there Space
Station Linda and staple encounter with
this circle is all of our baby
here's three
[Music]
you know I'm it I can't do anything like
guys so I'm just gonna be i'ma leave
them trapped for now
ah Jesus
oh damn it
death by Harbor hey Chanel what's up sad
- Chanel let's try this one more time
let's just go I don't want to do that
let's just go up the other thing there
I'll call a liberator
[Music]
hi version Achilles
I had my crew play GTA 5's is max honey
I'm Melanie this game is a mess but
she'll at McMinn met my old chat the
same is a beautiful mess action it's
really fun it's super weird but it's
like I'm having a great time playing it
it's called the Magic Circle by the way
just like this if you're watching 360
it's like a Magic Circle
exactly that's why we we planned that
exactly we didn't actually plan it but
we did what's going on minecraft madness
love the town of Salem's - siren siren
siren away we've been up here we've done
this yeah
[Music]
when I got hit with the chair and the
wabe it was it hurt but those were
breakaway chairs
I had specially made for Conan's so he
didn't kill me when he hit me with them
haha actually he didn't even want to
really I came up with that things I
thought would be a funny way to rate the
game when Conan still did ratings I'm
clueless gamer then he didn't even want
to use them and I was like oh man but I
had them build these chairs especially
as like all right and so then we did it
so I actually had to beg him to hit me
with the chair which is a weird part of
my job alright so here's the problem
well you know we should do is just going
we should go in rather than going up on
the thing I think we should go in the
tubes yeah oh wait let's go up here see
what's up here
I just need a couple hollers you know
help a brother out this is bad
nope nope nope nope nope no we're nope
anon here no no nope no thank you no
thank you no thank you I don't want your
hiver
oh come on guys
there's so much faster than me
oh I trapped in both
can I just go in here yeah nope that's a
trap can I go in here yep look let's see
what this thing is what is this thing
what is this there come the hiver salut
what is that
here they come so dark this is very
creepy in here man oh you know what I
can throw a rock at him that'll work I
[Music]
lost goddamn mind to push this mushroom
no oh my god
I remember this speech from the matrix -
please
okay I don't wait the hollers down here
right I'm a boy
[Music]
collars back also I'm turning this thing
on whatever this is my enemies are high
vers
my allies are zero
oh you tax with nothing tractor beam
okay fine
this is gonna be ridiculous
[Music]
you can suck some bad guys over I did
why did I even do that that was stupid
let's edit him let's let's take this
tracking me back you taxes nothing sorry
your gotta go oh I wonder if I
could get the tractor beam oh I'm gonna
get the tractor beam - you bet
oh thank you thinking about that idea Oh
jack
no cuz then you won't be able to just
melee oh that's true all right let's go
it's in here oh god we have to go up and
kill all these things all right well I
got a rock right can I hit with the rock
do you fire a shot oh I wonder if I
could put a tractor beam on the rock oh
yeah okay that's crazy huh but here's an
idea can I put a tractor beam on the
rock I move by yeah this is gonna be
great
my enemies are my allies our hero
enemies are high verse this is gonna be
dope oh this is dope Lee this guy let's
go now if they come near me I can just
throw something right this is gonna work
all right let's see what am I going here
I'm curious
this is so weird this game is crazy
it doesn't make you think though in a
fun way ha Wow get him get it with the
tractor beam oh no he's back though I
got killed man the hybrid just killed
the rock that easily ridiculous oh man
alright well I think this is gonna do it
guys it's 1:30
okay well it's fun this game was super
fun it's called the Magic Circle and
it's about making video games it was
super cool Aaron if you're reading I
just want to say something about cannons
I couldn't say with that I couldn't it
was too fast for me to see The Rock says
it doesn't matter what your tractor beam
does Oh Shirley duck best joke of the
screen please tune in to YouTube's
stream tonight we'll have you three
Kohner and I will be appearing I'm
talking about clueless gamer which will
be really fun that's at 7:30 Pacific
time tonight hope you all are tuning in
to e3 coverage and enjoying that
please watch our show this evening at 11
p.m. Monday through Thursdays on TBS or
a team koco.com and I hope you've
enjoyed this 360 stream it's like
playing with us right it's like sitting
here with us which is really cool on
stream Coco that's right exactly without
all this stench we will see you guys
next Monday for another really fun
stream Coco I think we'll play some
overwatch with you guys that's right
we've got some gas we're gonna play
maybe some overwatch and so sharpen your
skills to take us down so thank you guys
it's super fun see you guys next Monday
you